day two of hybrid learning for the clark
county school district roughly 20 000
students returned to class
yesterday and today good afternoon
thanks so much for joining us here at
four o'clock i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casarez 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond is live in the
newsroom
with the latest on the transition and
the issues kristen
well kirsten and christian the district
various families and
administrators tell me hybrid learning
is going well so far
only a few minor issues with technology
but overall
a welcome difference compared to the
start of distance education in the fall
when the online classroom software
called canvas crashed
not the case the last two days it seems
students and staff are adjusting well
despite the changes that includes
educators live streaming lessons for
students attending remotely
while also teaching kids in class i'm
told students are following the new
safety guidelines like wearing a mask
and social distancing but
some teachers want to remind families
find masks that appropriately are
sized for their child's face now
regarding technology the nevada parent
teacher association president tells me
she knows of a few issues i did hear
that there were some technology issues
yesterday with
even with the best intentions of trying
to have all the streaming
processes and cameras set up and things
like that that there were some
challenges with how to get onto this
google me
a couple unions mentioned staff having
trouble logging into the e-mocha health
program
that's the platform that allows staff to
monitor their daily symptoms
which is a district requirement i
reached out to ccsd but have not
received a response yet about that
now coming up at five i talked to
teachers as well or i'm sorry i talked
to a parent as well as a principal about
adjusting to hybrid learning
and if there will be possible changes at
the principal school for cohort b's
first day
back on thursday reporting live in the
newsroom kristen drummond
8 news now